good morning believe nation today's
message is enjoy the process over to you
Matthew McConaughey the actual making of
a film the day-to-day go into work the
construction of them has always been my
favorite thing I like making it feel
much more than I like watching them I do
and even the ones I'm in I really love
the coming together with a whole bunch
of people having an idea on paper and
everyone's got everyone's an expert at
what they do and you're and you're off
on this journey you've got ideas but
then you just let him do let it let it
go and see what it can become
I love the making that's when I'm
happiest is when I'm making a film or
telling their story the day to day and
more so than watching them really the
mean look I kind of define that for
myself about four years ago process
prizes stay in process head down in
process stay in your bubble and when
it's over be that fulfillment notice
when I started noticing that fulfillment
of it I just finished well that's enough
that's it I don't know if this thing I
don't know if it's even coming out I
don't even know I don't know what it's
gonna turn in man I hope they I hope we
got it and I hope the director put
something good together but I don't know
nothing I can do about that all I know
is this experience that I said go have
the experience McConaughey and if I can
love this experience and at the end of
it I'm like may never even hear that
film again may never even know that
story again it may be gone let me find
out that all the negatives cut fried the
x-ray machine there is no film but I've
got to be that's okay I had an
experience when I got selfish for that
for that experience when I got that
process enjoying that process the day to
day architecture of making a movie and
creating a role that's that's what I've
been the happiest and more results have
come that way in an odd way you know
but I just saw when I started really
approached them as this is a finite
thing and this is just to experience
other than that I'm not producing this
thing I'm not the one editing thing I
don't know what it's gonna be that's it
and then all of a sudden they come out
and go oh he who's got a good one this
is one of my favorite messages and if I
had to give advice to somebody to have
success in any field not just
entrepreneurship in any field you look
at the people have the most success in
any field they enjoy the process and too
many people are attached just to the
outcome if you want to make a
blockbuster hit if you want to make a
successful movie you have to enjoy the
process of making movies as an
entrepreneur if you want to have a
successful product you want to have a
great service that's making a lot of
money you want to have a huge business
whatever you define as huge or
successful then you need to enjoy the
process of the work that you're doing on
a day to day basis and not everything is
gonna be amazing you're gonna have down
days but net-net
you have to enjoy what you're doing you
have to wake up and look forward to the
day that is ahead and too many
entrepreneurs are spending 80 to 90
percent of their time doing stuff that
they're not good at that they don't want
to be good at that they hate because
they feel they need to do it to grow
their business and only 10 to 20 percent
of their time on the stuff that they can
be genius-level act and you will not
have success in any endeavor if you are
only spending 10 to 20 percent of your
time or less on the stuff that you have
the potential to be the best in the
world at and that you enjoy if your goal
is just to make a lot of money and
you'll do whatever it takes just to make
that amount of money you'll never get
there because you don't enjoy the work
where the secret to success is enjoying
the day-to-day grind because it doesn't
feel like a grind it feels enjoy so the
question of day today is what is it
about your grind that you love every day
what's the best part of your work leave
in the comments below and I will join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Barbie Dukes Barbie
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book you guys watching if you want
to change that a shout out in a future
video make sure to grab the book and
also email in your receipt so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching have a
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso